what's happening Beth murasky and I are
here with Jason O'Malley Jim Apollo and
iris what's your last name iris Rican
Touche
well Ola racist party we're good we're
green today because we're trying out a
little thing that literally every other
streamer and the entire universe does
they put themselves in the video game
and we're gonna do that in a little game
called monster hunter world I'm very
excited today I'm very i wear my no gods
because it's only monsters today look at
this look at we're in the world it's
crazy and this is literally I think the
worst possible world to be in because
there's monsters in here why why
wouldn't we put ourselves in like Super
Mario where there's free gold everywhere
we're we're dumb this is the stupidest
thing ever
ahh can I tell come you said hello yes
game thug 21 I'll make sure to tell
Conan you said hi
hello richer hum well love the name well
done sir it's like when you were 13 and
you made a club called the pen15 Club
yeah we're that ha ha ha ha well done
handy what's up Oh Andy likes it Andy
likes it already that's right oh snap
we've got all fancy waffle tarts that's
true
we're super fancy all right let's do it
also the cool thing about this is if
there's something you know how we have
like a box normally how we're normally
and like a not I could do a whole look
at this I got a whole mine thing going
uh if there's like something behind us
we can just go if there's like bullet
you're like bullet count or something
here oh yeah just be like oh how many
more bullets we got we can just move out
of the way and it's right there oh now
we're bigger this is horrifying there we
go pretty exciting this is gonna be
awesome as this shadow bat shadow but I
like your name um now look I love
monsters I'm not a fan of hunting I
don't really like hunting in real life
because I think if you're gonna be if
you're gonna hunt something you should
use the same weapons that the animal has
so if you're gonna hunt deer you should
have to hunt a deer by putting antlers
on your head and going you know what I'm
saying about like yeah and you put sharp
teeth in huh yeah
I think it should be an even playing
field with hundred I don't like or you
should like if it's you're hunting
raccoons because they have opposable
thumbs then you give them little guns
you know and then it's like you got to
make it even man this is gonna be
awesome as this case yes Hobbit it's
already awesome right this is great I
like any game that starts with if you've
lost your nerve step away now that's
true look at this now here's the thing
though about this game I I think that
the hunt from what I've read I think the
hunting is gonna be great because we
have less weapons than the animals have
in this we only have like a sword and
they're huge and have giant so we're at
the disadvantage I think right in a
monster hunter world how would you hunt
a monster what would be your plan of
attack I try well that's a terrible idea
how is diplomacy gonna work here yeah
let's make it a little bit louder shall
we
that's me little Click Clack on the
cheek check uh how's diplomacy gonna
work how did you speak monster yeah okay
well fair enough Wow everybody's
overdressed this looks like basically
your typical like hipster bar this is
every this is just like me yeah this is
a this is a Friday oh wow it's digimon
ooh wow uh the wasteland scavenger when
fighting monsters one of us be careful
not to become one that's some deep the
chat bringing some deep deep platitudes
I love this I also love you know my
favorite thing about this new set up is
my forehead is extra shiny yeah I think
that's fantastic yeah look at that just
right oh yeah you know what I think we
should hunt this monster right here we
do masks
I want this lady's hair cut do it dude
you have the power to get this hair cut
right here also look at we're in the
game look I could just reach out and I
can poke this person poke poke
oh wait what's our name what's our name
B oh oh you know what I think we should
be a lady be a lady hunter yeah
all right presets let's go through the
presets a little I mean this is always
kind of the most fun part look at this
Bob makeover I think it's important not
to have long hair because we don't want
it you know to like get in our way or
fighting monsters I'm a fan I say either
the Bob or this thing I say one of these
two okay that's true yeah but we gotta
stay on brands stay on brand always oh
wait don't cancel these changes all
right how do i what do i how do I get
out of here
well so I'm not in favor of like the one
shoulder on one shoulder off this is
gonna give us like a worst han line ever
yes we're just gonna get one shoulder
sunburned and one shoulder bike pale
fish-belly white
all right confirm the preset I don't
know well what do you think about this
is all I don't care about this do we
care about this given us some cheeks you
know I feel like we got some cheeks we
can maybe hide food and our cheeks like
a gerbil you know okay this is yeah
let's get y'all to get some good brows
going on what a good what our good brows
that we want but what's our brow
situation here oh my God look at how
many brow types there are guys this is
amazing
all right this gives us kind of a gentle
hunter II look we can just play this the
whole time yeah I love you know what
there should be I'm sure there is a game
that's like this this is like the
Columbo eyes exactly hamster bleh that's
me
Connor was always my favorite late-night
host well thank you for putting that in
past it's very nice of you there you go
you still have a show believe it or not
okay this is fine this is fine
oh this is fine oh wait facial hair
facial hair oh this is cool who should
we do like a full beard what do you
think about this idea lady
now let's no I'm not into that it looks
more it's just it's just gonna look fake
and then everyone every monster we come
in contact with is gonna be like is that
fake I'm like no it's real well let's
look at our expression I don't want
wretched resting [ __ ]
maybe we do want resting [ __ ] whose
expressions these expressions aren't
doing any oh pretty the expression oh
[Music]
[Music]
this is the fakest smile I've ever seen
oh oh I see oh you can go through all
the expressions hello there's wow this
is amazing crazy I liked I know I'm
cutting into this just for this one uh
yeah this is the expression most women
give me by the way uh when you go
monster engine you're like oh I don't
want to do it alright clothing this is
important all right okay that's it
that's all we got well I hate the one on
one off thing but I also think this is
ridiculous to hunt monsters yeah you're
just asking for cuts on your tongue yeah
what are you doing alright let's do this
I'm fine with default voice oh cool oh
that's just our undergarments three is
the best Murata alright um voice that's
our voice this is making me feel weird I
don't like this I'm not into this it
just sounds like we're listening to like
women's tennis this is like wimpleton
like well that's how I love the idea of
a an actor being called in I'm sorry we
didn't get you we need you to come back
in to do the grunts yeah we missed type
eight this is like stomach flu
which does a toast what is the
difference of all here's a question why
didn't they just make one why do we have
to choose why don't they just make one
person with like a thousand different
things to make it more realistic
this is she's just upset uh all right
we're doing this one uh uh I like this
one all right I like it
default armor whoo leather chain maille
holy Moses no armor
I say leather man hello there's cool
let's keep it yeah yeah this is gonna
keep it right keep it tight enter our
name Oh Oh easy Beth no no no we be can
we be can I use your last name no no
wait why don't we make it a combination
of our two names what about if it's
black lace what there it's a combination
of mean and bad place exactly yeah this
is gonna be great
oh look at this palek Oh oh my god now
that's it I have this gonna be named
Beth no oh this is great
Beth Oh Beth Lee uh can't green-screen
the bruises away what does that mean
oh I guess when I get hit oh my god Beth
look at this oh my god oh lordy oh I
like this one oh my oh this is my new
favorite game which one are we gonna
choose this is so good whoo this is guys
ever colored Isaac David Bowie I like
this guy or girl or but I don't know
what do you think that you get to choose
you
let's go through all them you choose
okay this one this one this one this one
this one this one this one this one this
one this one this one I like the round
ear this one Oh God so adorable oh my
god enough hurt you guys this is a meet
these graphics are great
the eyes closed cat yeah waffle tarts
you chose that one earn old Berisha says
Wow Wow
she doesn't care my god that woman
turned into a cat no I think we can do a
long hair short hair I'm not a fan of
the short or long hair looks great what
do you think about what's your what's
your thought on fur thickness grooming
yeah it's too thin further though I mean
we want it to be kind of supple well
just leave it
what about oh my God look at these color
presets or do you just like it all white
I like our white without a little like
eyepatch it's cool okay cool
wait this is wait I think I messed it up
somehow oh wait how do I get back to you
as regular oh here we go
all right oh god no it's all fine
oh this is good oh my god we could
change the pattern but look at this too
much power this is too much power
oh you know I think we just stick with
though what we do like what drew us to
this cat originally eyes ears tail oh my
get oh I don't like I think I think we
want like I don't like a stub tail yeah
oh all right that's never been more to
again hey stats booster what's up uh
mEEMIC cat boy cat designer 2018 looks
like a great little clothing oh my god I
think it's fine oh my God look at this
cat oh my god Beth how excited are you
at this cat wait the tapes are like the
same note way of the voice
[Music]
oh this one cuteness overload
oh wait armor no armor we like the armor
do we like the no armor I feel like we
want to protect your kid all right
this is great I already love this game
oh now what's our name everybody what's
the name
meow best cat simulator ever Beth stop
denying your real name two legged cat
man hmm
airborne cat I mean cocoa everyone's
saying cocoa all right well name a cocoa
it's a great cat yeah cocoa the cats a
good name oops whoops cocktail BAM
yes it's great all right look at this oh
look at his little bum oh my god can we
just play our palek oh yeah can we just
play as the cat this is amazing I love
this game already
Batman Pablo now renamed Emma cocoa not
shlonsky come on Conan cutes is chunky
salsa how about a toast to our little
kitty oh this is us great I love this
game man even if we don't get to kill
any monster it's just running around
with a cat is so great all right well
here we go with the plot and you have it
a Yabba Yabba de
those are some big-ass mugs that mug in
real life was like this big even the cat
has to drink so adorable we forgot to
pick his litter box brain to Michael we
didn't get a chance
Yeah right exactly he drinks
Oh our palico uh-oh
also is that glowing radiation thing
gonna give us some weird kind of cancer
skip the cutscene yeah should we skip
the cutscenes we skip this I want to see
our cat in action kinda do I like Star
Wars games like Jedi Academy there are
some good Star Wars games out there yeah
yes I'm gonna start singing Audi dude
everybody's Maddy do Coco cat
most cute cat ever oh there comes a
monster let's hunt a death are we
hunting monsters are the monsters
hunting us I ask you oh we're on a ship
or in a boat plot twist
Oh No oh my god this is like Pacific Rim
in like medieval times holy crap I feel
like we don't have enough weapons or any
weapons dude oh my god oh no it's a
glass scene in Titanic
spoiler alert the boat sinks that tell
us that's right
Toblerone I I'm I'm actually 13 sorry
I'm very young Conan's one of the cringe
ease people ever I agree 100%
no wait Coco the cat no right okay all
right here we are we're stuck on a giant
lava spike' that's come out of the
ground I really feel like we should be
wearing pants you know one thing I gotta
say that I find super annoying and this
is goes for comic books to like dress
women warriors like they would actually
dress don't like put like hot pants on a
monster hunter give her some armor man
what if we get hit in the legs
what's gonna
laughing all right here we go uh all
right oh boy oh boy oh boy fire okay we
got a roll here we got a thing those
don't do anything there's no jump
there's just a roll where did the cat go
yeah I know I'm worried actually can I
climb uh I'm guessing I can't jump into
that lava oh you know what I can climb
up this thing right or something it's
climb wall climbing I'd like to climb
the wall oh all right oh dude oh we got
a little hook pay the handler yeah the
ship is what I like to call totally
effed I'm on the monster this is like a
crazy shadow that we held last week we
play Shadow of the Colossus with just
another monster fighting game this is
like Shadow the Colossus on like
steroids yeah it's right a bucket we
just yep the guy should also have hot
pants yeah you're you what you're right
yeah I agree there it should either be
hot pants yeah yeah exactly
exactly oh boy well I guess our ships
fine and leaving without us so that
sucks
ooh a nice fine tune in that green
screen there a mouse
I love it man I love it oh boy this is
bad for us oh boy this is real bad
luckily I got my trusty you know I want
to start using in Rio we got some bats
we got Minnie hunt oh this is cool you
know oh no I love by the way any game
that like starts us off in the thick of
things I'm into you know how I hate
games with slow starts this is great
like Uncharted is another game that does
that a lot and really well oh this is
awesome oh my god I'm gonna get totally
effed by this thing whoa
let's go baby wyverns I hate wyverns I
don't even know what a wyvern is
hot pants with Robin Williams like oh my
god holy crap this is the worst climbing
gym I've ever been to
Martian Manhunter has always been the
great no pants equalizer I guess he's a
Martian though and legs also the least
sexy of all the superheroes he's green
and you know oh my god all right oh geez
oh boy
oh brother oh wait did I mean to do that
yeah grab your pal yes oh dude we're in
the game look at this it's crazy if I
pull my legs up it kind of looks like
I'm flying
[Music]
damn wow that monsters a dick a wyvern
is a dragon with wings attached to their
front legs and arms okay it's like a bat
dragon we're a bragging as I call it
which is something I do often don't
worry about it you should you should
gain Teva hooked up to a stage harness
so it does look like you're flying
that's a good idea you know what here's
the thing about monsters they're just
people you know just like us
they just want to go home and eat stuff
and chill out watch TV their family team
cook I got better specs then uh are we
guys getting paid right now while I work
on salary Jesse
so technically yeah all right deduct
this time Yeah right dude we're not
we're not not getting paid yeah so yeah
we are technically getting paid
he's driving Elon Musk Tesla I don't
know exactly what that joke is but I'm
gonna laugh at it because it seems
polite actually it's funny well here we
are so basically this is like lost that
TV show lost only with monsters and
talking cats can you please tell me
they're gonna do clues gamer coming soon
I wish I could stay tuned stay car tuned
alright so now I'm guessing that we've
gone past the really fun part there's
gonna be like a bunch of boring stuff
yep open and close map okay yeah now
it's boring hey you know what we did
have a good run though for a while yes
oh we get to go to the research
Commission wow this game is just super
exciting I think so too
great let's go hopefully we'll run into
like 19 monsters on the way it is pretty
game
face the wrong oh we just got to follow
our pal here alright okay relax
wow you're clingy ooh there we go sexy
shot oh yeah this is very Jurassic Park
II I can't wait to fight all these
animals ancient forest hunt monsters
that said you win how am i alive gaming
range how are any of us alive really
it's kind of amazing when you think
about how many people had to live for
you to be alive so many people think
about how many accidents if you're me
you survive on a yearly basis and then
think about how many people that you had
to had to survive for you to could I
just run around here
I think just I'm just gonna run straight
you know what helped oh look at these
little things I can't do anything so I
guess I have to still get I guess I'm
gonna get a weapon at the research
Commission
all right don't try to make me care
about these things I don't care about
here we go all right can I map I do
enjoy the little map thing uh we gotta
go around how brother where are you at
this game is pretty though hi Terra
you make the cam smaller oh yeah key
will shrink us down what you want no one
to see hourglass of us II understand why
why would you do this yeah oh don't
touch it the last thing you should do is
like futz around with weird plants oh
great
where are you again hmm
scout flies memorize your scent gross so
basically you smell so bad that I can
see you on my map that's weird
wow man you really should shower how
about that stead of having the Scout
Flies memorize your scent why don't you
just shower once in a while all right
here we go
oh through here perfect Oh
can't get through Oh push through the
vines I like that ooh this is cool
bigger more of us sorry goodbye friend
goodbye follow the funks is a Zurich hey
Erin Blair could I get a chance to date
Miranda Cosgrove this year if it's
possible who's Miranda Cosgrove
whoa I don't know man you should header
up on Twitter or something I don't know
who that is
uh-oh this gecko looks really pissed off
whoa whoa all right
clever girl whoo this is cool I like
this oh no the girl from icarly I see
whoa yeah no [ __ ]
all right don't pick a fight if we don't
need to the game is called Monster
Hunter what are you talking about hurry
up and hide oh yeah
yeah they didn't see us wanting in here
and by the way Claire why am i hiding
this is the girl with the smell of it
the funk that's so bad that I can track
her you're terrible hiding all right
yeah they won't be able to track us then
I'm with the smelliest girl on the
Monster Hunter world here we go let's
push through more vines in a very weird
way yeah des booster says the best way
to get a celebrity these days is to
tweet them a prom invite that's true
just ask them to the prom and if you
don't have a problem then ask them to a
problem and then crash it your
electricity shutoff on you and you're in
the shower last week does your shower
run on electricity that seems bad it's
like a bigger problem than whoo look at
that so far this game is very pretty and
you know again it started with action
which I love what is it I'm having
trouble concentrating with your funk old
footprints okay luckily though there's
no fall damage says rising seven there
we go
I love a game with no fall damage I
crazy or I can literally count the
frames or the amount of frames this
stream is running at so you can count to
thirty or sixty yeah that's good I'm
glad education is priority for you oh
boy oh no oh no no what do i do oh nice
that guy's got a huge sword alright
Bradley Cooper with a sword is why would
I run in the same direction is the thing
but fine here I come
yeah our chairs are pretty crappy these
are some oh snap my god there's so many
monsters around here nice keep standing
underneath the giant monster so you get
killed that's a good everything damn Sun
woo I can't believe all this is just
going on right behind us I know boom Wow
jacoco make you earn cut the clueless
gamer budget by streaming four bits on
twitch no rising seven it's not a stick
he is actually terrible video games
people always think it's a stick and
then they actually see him in the room
and it's not a stick
Conan's my hero that is true damn your
character is fugly move Jonathan Perez
aren't we feeling a judgmental today did
we mean to make our character look like
a young Conan yeah I think we did yeah
we chose the hair of the conan and
Conan's true gender it's true easy no
just he's a 13 year old girl I like
Facebook in the top comment is like who
is this - woman it's - toy it's yeah
Toria Hallinan come to life the cat is
cute I agree I'm just getting started
yeah take it well I am actually super
excited about this game this game looked
really dope and it continues to be deaf
but also where is the cat that's
inquiring minds want to know where is de
kitty cat where that cat hashtag where
that cat
all right can I skip this can I skip
this can I skip this and I skip this
can't skip this all right
oh boy
everybody here is dressed like they're
in the circus she's wearing a tube sock
around her neck she's definitely worried
that's definitely a tube sock right the
green girl has around her neck maybe the
cats on the ship
fair enough lost in twitch worse fair
enough weird a cat Thank You Sheree be
know raise you Coco cat google it wear
that cat I wouldn't google anything
frankly it's just gonna lead you to porn
everything stay off the internet it's
terrible why wouldn't we have explorers
do the exploring have research do that
oh my god these people are all and I've
liked mice where is huge and pointless
cat-boy
dizzy death and I do Anna next cooking
stream will be uh well it's not gonna be
it's gonna be in three weeks not this
Friday not the next Friday the following
Friday I'll make a post about it don't
worry my burn though actually healed
look at my burn healed all up right
there Oh healed all up
got a big blister all right okay
pulled you into speed okay yep yep yep
yep guilt spoke highly of you yep go
ahead okay wander around now they're
gonna give us some meaning meaningless
tasks that we need to do in the town
right which is what always happens you
might with the bow for this game all
right yeah I think I'm gonna go for bow
also I like like it's Skyrim I like a
sniper situation you know especially in
Monster Hunter I like a game where you
could stay away from the monsters in
call that I was always the mage where
the elf though because you could fire in
long distances
okay let's all walk as slow as possible
man let's just get past three weeks what
am I made of week sorry dizzy daddy I'm
going out of town for next few weeks and
I'll be back and then we're gonna be
doing some crazy streams but in the
meantime I'm gonna put together a dinner
in a video game website so that'll be
fun it's a possible ask George slansky
Jordan doesn't like video games and it I
think it's a little frightened by them I
don't think I mean we'll definitely have
him at some point play some names but he
doesn't like doing things he's not good
at wouldn't you say that that's a nice
husband Jordan he only really likes to
look like an expert at all times so he
doesn't really like that even though
like even the Star Wars video game he
refused to play oh yeah mommy loves
daddy I don't know but thank you for
joining us
okay you're showing me things I don't
care about what am i doing follow team
leader set up to the canteen alright
this is all can you just skip this can
you skip this equipment alright hey
what's up coffee kills try going into
training area and testing all the
weapons do I have to do all this stuff
first how many people in the chat
applied this game that's what I want to
know you'd spend the whole stream
talking about vs you're right oh scream
oh thank you I see a cat oh I see little
kitties kitties everyone in this world
has awesome hair I think it'd be great
to be a hairdresser in this world whoa
there's our cat oh yes oh my god and his
also his bag as a little cat his little
canteen as a cat oh my god he's huge by
the way his head is the size the size of
her head also be super high
I'm catnip 24/7 that guy's got some big
man boobs Monster Hunter Barbour edition
of three yes that'd be amazing
all right let's begin council nope
okay ready all right yeah yeah yeah okay
that's a big-ass cat right there hashtag
big-ass cat the J strim I don't know
what what is Tom Brady's daily routine
he's like a very strict very strict
daily routine maybe oh that would be
great
waffle tarts it's a little above us can
we just all look at the cat's for a
while the cheese blog I would love to
yeah all right here's this dude you have
your uh everybody's here you got the old
weird mistrustful pale elf there on the
left you have the bald guy with the eye
patch
you got the giant huge scary cat you got
a big map it's basically you know your
typical like you have we got the minor
guy oh yeah every everybody all you have
in all fantasy you have your fellowship
Zachary always that cat's been through
some stuff sister Kirra yeah all right
first mission this Jaguars problem we'll
need a weapon all right a box full of
equipment weird advice if we're going
sniper use the bow because all the other
gun range weapons are really bad okay
cool thank you Jonathan Perez okay
where's that I think I'm gonna bow
everyone's telling me to go bow which I
like
oh my rooms right here look at this
love this little Airbnb situation Brady
doesn't like to eat sugar white flour
olive oil idle iodized salt tomatoes
peppers mushrooms eggplants all caffeine
and dairy products dan was he just like
eats area-specific Wow
I met Tom Brady he was a really nice guy
least to me these cats are tough
then our nine lives they live knives oh
that was actually great wallets give
yourself some credit
there's other cats in here you know what
it's fine when a cat cleans itself but
if it's like man-sized cat that's gross
I don't want to mind that all right
change equipment ah great swords sword
and shield heavy bow gun
so we not the heavy bow gun right okay
okay all we have is a hunter's knife
perfect all right leather key what is
what's what's happening wait man I you
know what one thing I suck at inventory
I I suck at it I'm just not good
I'm not good navigating this whole thing
oh here we go equipment box all right
here we go Buster Sword katana gun Lance
chain blitz iron bow this is what we
want right iron bow and then also I can
I also get like some sword or something
well you could play a movie yeah I'm
into that
Gunter's are shown just say if you skip
all the tutorial boxes you're gonna run
around confused wondering how to do
things yes iron bow all right
test all that fits first only one at a
time Aaron s elf blood man I got
something
all right we're going on your bow guys
we're doing it that's all I can use
though right I guess so
it's only letting me do one or should we
get in there with the katana hey a valid
or I love Brazil we do everything oh
yeah I've been there it's awesome Amazon
man bring the ring to Mordor that's what
I'm saying yeah now we're talking all
right cats
we got a boom we got a big look how
biggest bullies do did huh but I guess
for a hunting big monsters I guess yeah
but make them a new tutorial is added
all right I said let's just get into the
quest all right
I think I'd know how to use a bow I've
been I've been around a few games you
know fair enough don't care ooh that's a
good question
wouldn't it be funny if they're like
we're the size of cats cats are
normal-sized whoa wouldn't it be funny
if at some point later in the game you
come across real humans and like the
monster show it like saw me yeah they're
just like we're huge and the monsters
are really tiny we go
team leader BAM I'm gonna sign up for a
quest man I'm ready let's get a quest
going how much more time we got on this
stream I wanted to fight at least one
monster we can do it 15 minutes uh let's
do it
okay
okay that's cool you know what we're not
just hunting the creatures we're trying
to understand them I think that's great
see knowing nature that's something we
could do I like this okay now he's
saying a bunch of [ __ ] I don't care
about here we go all right captain let's
go my calf is not wearing a shirt okay
you know what I was bitching earlier
about ladies being the least dressed and
now I take it back yeah yeah also I wish
this guy would put on a shirt can I just
start a I've talked to handler in the
canteen god damn where's the canteen
again is just down here right over here
it's look at our map oh here it is this
is a sink the handler boom that's where
we go all right and that would be this
way all right I'm coming I got to find
you though dude we're not cantina uh
canteen this way oh the canteens up the
stairs that's right yeah I wouldn't kill
them to put like a elevator or something
around here wait I can't canteens up
here oh there's an elevator which looks
like a bunch of moving change yeah there
was a lot of stairs man although you
know what I got to get my cardio if I'm
gonna fight these monsters Zombieland
rule number one cardio and rule number
two I think all right here we go all
right we're up here I would put the
canteen on the first floor just because
everybody has to go and it's really
annoying
yeah come on what is this a cruise ship
okay yeah exit tutorial I don't need to
eat yes exit the tutorial I know I don't
care god damn it where's the handler
you're supposed to meet me here
oh they're shoes all right let's go time
request like a ski lift
you're a rope tow or something
you're my hunter and I'm your hand I
love this bread your butter I'm in let's
do it v okay that's great
okay depart yeah uh I gotta sign up for
the I don't know let's go
post a new quest yeah okay I accept the
quest yep a sign I love it let's do it
I'm in I'm in I'm in let's do it quest
accepted
ciao we have to wait for preparations
god dammit uh preparations have to be
completed what if I get you know what's
interesting is like look at this is it
up there you know top of my head yeah
there you go I kind of like this idea
right here
all right well lathe is still waiting
for our quest oh here we go
boom yes perfect oh yes all right cats
come with us this is great
okay okay okay don't carry on okay okay
great all the character modifications
carry into cutscenes oh that's true that
is really cool oh yeah I do like that
yeah yeah sorry tip olya eat eat eat I
should have eaten uh oh wait why didn't
I uh oh
I should have eaten I'm super hungry in
real life so it's good that we always do
this at lunchtime
yeah I agree hyped all right let's kill
a bunch of Jagger's check our map I do
like to map the map animation school man
let's go back what can you hear why
should i eat
they said you'll faint I'll faint oh my
god alright alright well let's look in
the supply box here maybe you have some
food for us that there we go you gain HP
and stamina where dem stacks I can't use
the power oh I see I have to do this or
something okay alright so can I eat now
oh behind me over here ooh
palek oh oh the snacks over here mrs. X
are in this area where dem snacks
oh the canteen here we go yeah
oven-roast no no exit tutorial oh wait
pay with money no not over no spares
money yeah oh meat platter what should
we eat
stamina hunters platter seems good
hunters platter
yeah hunters platter to get whoo here we
go
I was think are the WV commissary had a
hunter's platter right you do everyday
looks good yeah that's great oh my god
oh my God look at this oh yeah oh look
at our cat cats going to town on that
fish whoo okay sounds like the funnest
videogame
usiness I agree this game is dope all
right here we go
I'm definitely playing more of this game
after this dream all right okay new
tutorial we don't care let's find these
monsters yeah pop above
okay I just want to kill one thing
okay cool makes sense got it
all right let's get a move on all right
let's go
I'm ready I'm so dead
uh-uh whoa we're dough
oh Jesus
what yikes
wait can't I hide what happened to me
hiding damn son
can I kill one yep shite
get my ass beat over here also do I have
unlimited ammo probably not Oh
at what point does this thing die
it happened at some point got it well I
killed one so I'm happy oh yeah oh yeah
carve it up
Oh unlimited sis come to the show okay
good that's good
get another meat play oooh let's hunt
these mofos let's do some monster huntin
oh yeah baby what's this over here I see
oh it's our boy this is cool I feel like
there's gonna be crafting later I'm just
taking it's fun I just have a million
things I'm carrying with me oh yeah a
lot of crafting going on so I get some
red pit
this is gonna be a game I could see
right now where I'm gonna like just go
around collecting like a thousand things
who sports stuff I'm allergic
all right where we on here we got to
find these they're tough to find hi ho
take a potion HP oh my HP is low is all
right
wait how do I
but the problem
damnit
hmm okay
what Kames Ascona play let's see a
question uh I mean plays games with us
his staff in terms of like punching me
uh he plays we could play he's played
minecraft some other games plays games
with my heart all the time so quit
playing games in my heart Conan oh yeah
just like instinct said I gotta kill
seven of these things is crazy
alright I want to kill one more before
our stream is done how much time I got
five minutes five minutes alright we got
to find another Jaguar guys how do I do
that is the question inside the cave you
say okay is this the cave this looks
very cave ask where are you the map oh
there's a giant weird light here I see
one Oh shite I think I've done messed up
well here they come ah oh
he's attacking our cat get away my cat
I'm getting my ass P you know what I
think a sword might have had a better
choice but
ah my cat I think it's throwing it down
back there how this guy died
they're tough monsters Beth don't lose
your head
if I hit them they seem to not attack
suit that one of the mouth do I have
like a is there anything do I have
anything else I can use to fight him
punch him yeah oh yeah oh I got another
what is it whatever this thing does is
great no oh I take it back pull out the
boat
let's go these are pretty much the
weakest monster oh my god although I
like that I think that's great yeah do
they go back in their little cave or ooh
here we go
harvest them I think we can do it we
just got to kill one more jagira don't
forget to loot the bodies oh you know
that's my favorite part of any game oh
here we go
son of a [ __ ] Oh F F don't there's no
more that's good no cuz we got to kill
seven
there we go main objective get away from
my cat you sons of [ __ ] wait I think
my cat just ran away for no reason
out of range in range now though what is
this thing I'm shooting this looks it's
like a weird berry I'm like oh it's like
a bomb I think it is the auto aim is
pretty great on this it's pretty
forgiving which is good they just keep
coming
I mean can I kill all of them this is
just their nest they just keep showing
up because there's like oh they're like
a 10,000 of them everywhere oh I know
what's going on here
[Music]
all right we did it whoo objective
complete we did it kids thank you all
for joining us for this sweet this is
pretty great I do like the green screen
thing this was really fun ah the game is
monster hunter world I think it was
really great
here's what I like about it the cat the
cat number one great number one and also
being able to choose your cat and the
fur and like customizing your cat now I
would just love if we were a giant cat I
think that would be that's how to make
this equation oh my god that'd be
amazing yeah what about a game where a
cat isn't main character the humans a
psychic very smart very smart I'll be
otherwise this game is super fun I love
it start off with action graphics are
great actions good we managed to find
some Jaguars and kill it within an hour
which is amazing so uh yeah go and get
this game
it's incredible thank you all for
joining us we will not see you next week
we only week after we'll see you which
will be super fun make sure to watch our
show tonight we've got the amazing mail
Kumail Nanjiani from the big sick it's
gonna be on along with maybe a cameo by
which could be fantastic she's amazing
big fan Jones we love us some Van Jones
and a musical guest
what dude in the lion musical guest well
I was gonna be fantastic so make sure
you watch the show ah thank you all for
joining us
blades and cap lathe and Coco the cat
boy peace out
you